hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on 4 honor again
today's just going to be a really small
video there was a
tweet going live about some of the new
testing ground changes or the core
combat update and what those changes are
obviously the core combat update came
out with the launch of the new season
but they wanted to change a few of the
damage numbers a lot of people on reddit
and the forums and stuff were
complaining about some of the numbers
and
rightly so some of them were pretty
solid but there were some that just
didn't really make too much sense so
they're going to be slowly updating this
stuff but
we'll get into that as we get into the
video so it's always like to be if you
do enjoy subscribe if you're new
let's get started with today's video so
as i stated before this patch is not the
final step they said that they will
take time to improve the core combat
update that will continue to monitor the
in-game data they have
and the channels to follow how all the
changes are impacting everyone
and then patch accordingly so keep that
in mind there might be more videos in
the future of more of these changes
for the gist of the update as this isn't
a particularly large patch
some of the known issues here are that
peacekeeper second light is now
dodgeable when getting hit by the
initial
attack orochi's top finisher feint into
gb now works against
rolling highlanders offensive form
enhanced lights now have been adjusted
to cost 12 stamina
and then highlanders light light combo
is now dodgeable on block and
on hit when in revenge or if the
opponent is out of stamina so keep that
in mind
there is also a large variety of attacks
that are going to be damage reduced
jj's heavy finishers are now 35 as
opposed to 38
wardens top heavy finisher will now be
37 as opposed to 44.
centurion's heavy opener at max charge
used to do 33
now 30 and then for his heavy finishers
at minimum charge this was 29 down to 28
and then 40 down to 30 for the max
charge black pryor's full block stands
blockable heavy from 35 to 30.
lawbringer's unblockable heavy finisher
from 40 to 36
lawbringers like combo after heavy
finisher from 6 to 3
kensei's heavy chains from 34 to 30
kensei's top heavy finisher in specific
from 44-38
shinobi's ranged heavy from 29 to 25
shigoki's heavy opener at max charge is
now 35 as opposed to 38.
shugoke's heavy finisher is now 38 as
opposed to 44
highlanders offensive stance heavies are
now 35 as opposed to 37
and finally shaman's unblockable side
heavy finishers are now 36 as opposed to
41.
those are a lot of different damage
numbers but let's be honest unless you
play like every single character in this
game
only a couple of these characters might
be important so it does seem like a
congested amount of info but at least
for the common player that plays maybe
one to maybe three heroes at max
usually this isn't that big of a deal
and then you can really focus on those
damage numbers but just remember
everything i just mentioned
all those attacks even if you don't look
at the numbers all the specific attacks
that i just explained will be having
damage reduction
there's also going to be some changes to
out-of-lock damage so of course this is
when you are fighting an opponent and
you're out of luck usually sprint
attacks are the biggest culprit of this
but these are going to be for doing
lighter heavy attacks while out of luck
and
usually for these this is obviously
going to be more for attacking minions
in breach and stuff like that so
just kind of keep that in mind as not
many people are going to be attacking
each other when they're out of luck
unless there's some sort of specific
cheese move or anything like that but
that's more of the frame data small
stuff that not every player uses
for example for tiandi his light
finishers are going to be 10 as opposed
to 13
and his heavy finishers will now be 32
as opposed to 35.
shaolin gets a buff for the heavy
finishers these used to be 29 will now
be 32.
new sha's light finishers will now be 10
as opposed to 13.
pk's heavy openers are now 18 as opposed
to 29 so pretty big nerf there
and the heavy finishers are now 24 as
opposed to 34.
wardens out of lock chains are now 14 as
opposed to 15.
conker's out of lock heavy infant and
chains are now 35 as opposed to 32 so
slight buff
shinobi's out of lock heavy finishers
are 25 as opposed to 32
aramucha's heavy infinity chains are now
32 as opposed to 26
berserkers out of lock light infinite
chains are now going to be 13 as opposed
to 9 and then the openers after faint
will be 9 instead of 13. so a good mix
of buffs and nerfs with this one
see that was pretty much what was said
in the blog post now like i said there's
a lot of raw damage numbers no
anything that has to do with move speed
or anything like that so if you do want
to take anything away from this video
mostly pay attention to the characters
that you play
and then figure out the rest as you play
is it's it can be very complicated
trying to keep all these different
numbers in your head trying to remember
certain things so
at the end of the day just remember what
characters you play if they're even
mentioned in here
and then go from there and like i said
this is going to be the end of the video
they're probably going to be updating a
lot more of the com the core combat
update as we slowly get into later in
the season so expect more small videos
like this where we just go over small my
new patches but
these could have a lasting pretty big
impact on the game but with that like if
you do enjoy that subscribe if you're
new let me know what you think about the
new season in the comments down below
and take care peace out see you in a new
video
[Music]
you